[Música]
imaginen que estuviéramos en el año 2000
y entráramos a un laboratorio científico
que tiene un panel de control con varias
computadoras interconectadas
una pantalla
y en este laboratorio acaban de entrar
dos mujeres dos investigadoras entre la
mexicana especialista en psicotrópicas
reconstructiva mientras también la mujer
de 100 años con una cajita plateada en
su mano
la mujer de 100 años acá de esa cajita
un chip especial que coloca en un lugar
especial de la computadora
y todo está listo para empezar el
experimento las dos mujeres están listas
frente a una ventana
y al otro lado de la ventana lo que hay
es un jardín cerrado
lawley emocionada haciendo lo que le
gusta se ve radiante tiene 7 meses de
embarazo la mujer de 100 años cumpliendo
con una meta importante de su vida
al otro lado de la ventana entra una
joven de 14 años con su cabeza
completamente rasurada
lo que vemos sobre su cráneo es cientos
de electrodos inalámbricos de acción
profunda que manipulan sus conexiones
neuronales
media hora antes él también tomó un
brebaje especial que lo que hace es
promover la producción de
neurotransmisores opioides en su cerebro
y esta joven entonces lo que hace se
empieza a caminar por el jardín cerrado
y hay algo entre las plantas que le
llama la atención entonces decide
acercarse a ver qué es eso y luego
aparece algún tipo de animal es como
alargado y está caminando sobre la
planta
entonces tomé esa planta para ver un
poquito más de cerca
y lo quiero acercar a la luz para ver si
si lo ve mejor pero la luz como que no
refleja sobre la superficie de la piel
decide dejarlo que camine sobre su mano
para verlo un poquito mejor y lo voy a
caminar sobre su mano pero no lo siente
al otro lado de la ventana
lawley y la mujer de 100 años saben que
la mano de él realmente está vacía
quien hubiera podido imaginar la ironía
que podría traer el futuro que aún en el
país con la mayor biodiversidad del
planeta algún día en el futuro solamente
se podría conocer una oruga por
alucinación dirigida
este proyecto es parte del trabajo del
ministerio de desarrollo humano y si yo
quisiera explicarles de la mejor manera
qué es lo que hace este ministerio la
calidad de hablarles cómo hablaría la
ministra de desarrollo humano del 2000
77 yo me imagino que
una ministra del futuro mínimo tiene
algún tipo de ropa no sea alguna moda
futurista así que me voy a poner algo
que me parece tal vez se pondría a ello
mínimo también algo tecnológico no sé
unos anteojos inteligentes
así que
yo creo que ya les diría algo así como
bueno gracias primero que todo por
invitarme a este télex del pasado
yo quisiera decirles que el 2000 77 ya
era inminente la necesidad de poner la
creatividad como una prioridad y
aprovechamos una reestructuración
nacional de todas las alianzas
público-privadas para crear lo que se
llama hoy el ministerio de desarrollo
humano
en este ministerio trabajamos bajo el
supuesto de que todos los seres humanos
somos creativos es parte de la
naturaleza de nuestra especie
pero para desarrollarlo al máximo hemos
creado una serie de centros los centros
de desarrollo humano y en ellos tenemos
proyectos abiertos para cualquier
persona que se quiera inscribir y bueno
como tengo poco tiempo tengo que
regresar a mis amistades les voy a dar
un ejemplo les quiero contar de un
ejemplo que es de un proyecto que se
desarrolló en el centro de desarrollo
humano segreda que es lo que antes se
conocía como el museo de arte
costarricense fusiona ahora con el liceo
y dobles segreda y el gimnasio nacional
y estas tres instituciones ahora
funcionan como una sola y reciben
personas de todas las edades
desarrollando proyectos y este proyecto
y surge de una preocupación por rescatar
el último guayacán real los
participantes del proyecto han ido a
guanacaste a la zona que está totalmente
cubierta por desierto en este momento y
rescatan el último árbol de esta especie
y lo colocan en una instalación que es
una función perfecta de ciencia y arte
las mismas ondas que mantienen el árbol
vivo nos envían información sobre sus
signos vitales y la proyectan en estas
pantallas en este tipo de cámara de
cuidados intensivos que tenemos para el
árbol
y bueno esta es una de las de las
señales por las que pensarán ustedes
tenemos muchas preocupaciones
la preocupación más importante para mí
es la pérdida de la biofilia humana
se han extinto las especies más
coloridas y carismáticas que teníamos y
los encuentros con ellas son cada vez
menos comunes y esto tiene una
consecuencia grave que es que las
personas no desarrollan esa biophilia
más bien hemos encontrado por
investigaciones que la falta de
expresión de la biofilia está
directamente relacionada con
comportamientos de agresión y depresión
entonces bueno espero que podamos hablar
más en el almuerzo después de la reunión
que tengo con la mujer de 100 años
porque justamente viene a traer el
microchip para que empecemos a la
siguiente etapa de investigaciones y
vamos a esperar a resolver los problemas
que tenemos de efectos secundarios
muchas gracias
bueno pero yo me subí que verdad yo no
estoy el futuro todavía si yo voy a
quitar esto porque estamos todavía en
en el 2017 no en el 2000 77
entonces tenemos 60 años de aquí a eso
hoy en la mañana una niña afuera de su
escuela a punto de entrar a la escuela
se encuentra algo que le llama la
atención entre el sacar y sacarte que
queda entre la acera y el caño siempre
y le llama la atención y se acerca para
ver qué es
será una oruga entonces hacer caso
humano con la planta se le queda viendo
y puede con la luz del sol ver sus
colores lo toca y se le eriza la piel
porque la textura era algo que no
esperaba además tiró unas antenas
anaranjadas con un olor veríssimo pero
le pareció como divertido
y las sigue sosteniendo para que no se
vaya a caer
hay un momento en que la ve cara a cara
y ve que en su cara tiene un patrón
perfecto de un corazón invertido
este
es el primero de muchos encuentros
cercanos de este tipo y esta niña
inspirada y transformada por estos
encuentros
seguirá su camino en la vida no sabemos
cuál será ese camino y esto puede hacer
cualquier niña actualmente en el 2017
tal vez escoja un camino artístico y se
convierta en la mentora que dirigió el
proyecto del último cuéllar can real
tal vez se haga una líder política
porque no la próxima ministra de
desarrollo humano tal vez se haga
científica
parte del equipo de la mujer de 100 años
no sabemos qué va a escoger
tal vez combine esas cosas en diferentes
momentos de su vida o tal vez describe
la historia completamente
sólo sabemos que inspirada y
transformada por estos encuentros ella
puede cambiar el futuro gracias
[Aplausos]